all right yeah so look at this look at
this this is uh this is art a concept
art or storyboard art from an artist
Phil langone who uh worked on Spider-Man
no way home and look you can see
Spider-Man is fighting Mysterio in this
concept art and it's not for Goblin it
is Mysterio who kills Aunt May this is
crazy and like he obviously it's so much
of this art other than the fact that
it's Mysterio is what is in the movie
The Anger that Peter has when he's like
attacking him right like uh some of this
battle was you know used at the end when
they're on the overturned Captain
America shield but like I mean Mysterio
was going to be part of this movie at
some point it sounds like it's so
interesting she had a feeling that he
was part of the plans I had a feeling
because like I had this weird theory
that like both Toby and Andrew were
Mysterio illusion so this makes me happy
oh and by the way we want to thank
nordvpn for sponsoring our show today
more on them in a bit it's so
interesting why Mysterio I think it hits
more that it wasn't stereo it was the
Green Goblin but that's just me yeah I
mean I I'm with you especially how good
Willem Dafoe was in this movie it was so
good amazing but you got to mention the
opening act of the movie it was tea
Mysterio who really ruined Peter
Parker's life at the beginning of the
movie in some ways no way home feels
like a segmented movie that way and this
kind of fits better with this segment I
I do agree like I would have loved to
see have this be like a Mysterio story
as well because like he's the whole
reason for the season he's the reason
why everything is happening so like
having Peter fight him and uh also the
dude from A Christmas Story for uh
releasing that video Yeah William Ginter
Reba one of the weirdest character names
for an actor named Peter Billingsley hey
welcome back to new rock stars was Aunt
May murdered by Mysterio in an alternate
universe well yes according to
storyboard concept art made for
Spider-Man no way home so as Marvel
Studios leaving its best ideas on The
Cutting Room floor you know whose fault
this is is
[Laughter]
this is inside Marvel it's new
Rockstar's weekly Marvel reaction show
and today we are reacting to and
spending this whole episode talking
about the concept art that always gets
released after Marvel film comes out
from the artists himself sometimes from
the studio when they release the art of
whatever it is in a book I'm Eric Voss
here with Jessica Clemens and Mt Hello
friends
that's why I dress up like this
a little artist you do look like an
artist I love it I love how you brought
up those little like art of books
because I love going through those books
too um after every Marvel movie comes
out because especially the Guardians of
the Galaxy ones there's so much more
information that you don't get in the
movies or even in the um yeah uh yeah as
a kid I grew up on visual dictionaries
whether it was a Star Wars visual
dictionaries they did them for like
Batman for Superman and uh yeah and for
Marvel for Game of Thrones like the the
world of Ice and Fire or whatever like I
love those coffee table books so good uh
I will never ever get up from like a
friend's house couch just reading those
books like Hey we're here socializing
like no no your coffee table literature
it's more interesting than you are
you're socializing a book I'm here to
read the parents coffee book I love
storyboard art I went to school for art
history and so I love looking at art and
I always will and for She-Hulk I was
obsessed with the uh storyboard artist
that would release all of She-Hulk
storyboard art and I was like this was
insane also I think there's so much
story behind the art like the fact that
they were gonna use Mysterio was a huge
deal it's like you guys were planning
for a Mysterio so what changed and what
is staying even the little remnants that
was Mysterio yeah I often forget that
you were an art history major Jess that
that explains like so much of how good
of a visual observant analysis and
allows sister you are uh because you
yeah like uh I feel like we all need to
take some art history classes and you
can teach it Jessica Jessica to teach us
exactly these things Professor Clemens
I'll be on time every class
kidding I'm always late but I'll be only
five minutes late okay thank you thank
you for that so A couple quick
announcements we want to make a reminder
to subscribe to the Deep dive Channel
we're gonna be doing some fun stuff over
there starting February 17th and hey be
sure to check out new rockstarsmerch.com
it's the only place to get shirts hats
and hoodies and so much more featuring
your favorite nerdy YouTube channel and
be sure to keep watching that merch
store because there's going to be some
Ant-Man that wants Quantum media
inspired merch coming very soon you can
support the channel and check out all of
our awesome merch options about new
roxasmirch.com our question today is
Marvel concept art better than the final
version of these movies that we get uh
can I can I say immediately yes go ahead
yes I'm gonna say yes because the
concept art didn't isn't in a box they
can do whatever they really want they
can put whatever they wanted and then
afterwards that's when they're like we
need to reel it back or something
happens down the line where they're like
hey we actually have to take this
completely out redo it the fact that it
was Mysterio and it was completely
changed I love concept art and also you
get a look at what their outfits were
supposed to look like before they were
supposed to get in here so it's like how
big can they go I I love it I love
concept art okay that's just me yeah and
this is a
H we should be fair to the directors and
writers who were um who made these
movies and were handsomely paid for it
but um the truth is that seeing the
picture of something our imaginations
kind of go to the best version of it
immediately and it's easier to compare
that to what we actually got and we may
have some other kind of associations
with with what we got you know the Grass
Is Always Greener right no in like to
Justice Point like yeah like the the
sky's the limit when it comes to concept
artists imagining what could possibly be
in this movie and like it's always going
to seem like oh my God I wish we got
that but at the end of the day you know
like the elements need to serve the
story and like if they change their
minds and like there's probably a good
reason for that right they always can
come back to it that's the that was the
situation with and She-Hulk in the
hallway it was just all concept art and
there was a lot of concept art that they
did use but a lot of concepts are they
did not use and I was like but they
still framed it and put it in the Marvel
Studios hallway as a look of like what
could have been and what is and so it's
like it's still highly regarding it's
still there it's always it's still out
there part of the Multiverse as we could
say right The Watcher knows okay let's
actually start with another piece of
Mysterio concept art from Spider-Man no
way home there's this one shot of
Mysterio fighting Doctor Strange by the
Statue of Liberty that came out at some
point last year I don't know if you guys
saw this
um but Mysterio and several different
versions of this movie was planned to be
the primary antagonist uh now we don't
know if this was a hollow projection of
Mysterio but it seemed like at some
point Mysterio was going to be revealed
to not actually have been dead after
Spider-Man far from home and I go back
and forth on this I liked Mysterio as a
villain but no way home would have kind
of been a rehash of uh it would have
been like a part two of Spider-Man far
from home in this version as opposed to
a full Multiverse story also do you
think you would have liked it more this
way I don't know it it it's really hard
because in no way home after finding out
it was like The Wizard of Oz just a man
behind a curtain was Mysterio I was like
it doesn't have that same pool fighting
Doctor Strange as the Green Goblin would
like that was an actual like villain
villain so but that's just me that's how
I felt about Mysterio I was like oh it's
just a man behind a curtain I think it
would have been would have been really
cool if Mysterio was a part of the movie
though like not the central part I think
that like having more MCU representation
in that whole Sinister team
um would have been dope I mean like
honestly like they should have had
scorpion in there let's be real
um they did nothing with scorpion but
like at the very least since this was a
sequel to far from home having the
studio there as a factor and like being
like hey I ruined your life but still
having Defoe you know mainly be like the
the main villain of that movie I feel
like would have been a good balance
between the two
um because Mysterio is like like the
main reason for the season he's the
reason why he did the spell in the first
place so I feel like he should have been
there hey you know what it could have
been is Mysterio from an alternate
universe like it could have been a
Mysterio who didn't die in London and uh
and is pissed that in this universe
Peter allowed him to die so like maybe
he was there alongside will Devoe is
Goblin and now for Molina's doctor
would he have been like released with
the other their villains because he knew
who Spider-Man was oh yeah maybe is that
what you're saying oh that's a good
point yeah he knows who he is I mean hey
that would have been better that would
have been sick than uh Sandman probably
or the lizard
look look here they try they try it
would have been really dope if they
alluded if that was like a rainy villain
for that um that Toby fought like after
Spider-Man 3 it's like oh yeah he's one
of mine like you know he's my Mysterio
is that your Mysterio hey could it have
been uh what's his face Bruce Campbell
Mysterio from Samurai loved it alternate
version
like everyone would have lost their [__]
bro everyone would have lost it I
guarantee you the person that made the
concept or was like this is exactly what
I was planning on doing
the possibility that like you know since
that adding grievances against Tony
Stark that this could have just been
somebody else who was just as crazy but
like somebody else I was part of the
team like maybe guterman I mean
ridiculous it feels good or man
but uh yeah like the stereo in the MCU
sort of seems like
um something that anyone could just like
yeah I'm surprised we haven't seen that
uh have we have we not really seen that
in the MCU yet it's in every comic that
someone takes someone's taking the Green
Goblin suit and put it on and was like
I'm the Green Goblin now so I'm just I'm
surprised they didn't actually go with
that it's it's an easy do they might be
saving it for probably yeah well that's
true we were talking about Bruce cable
let's actually move on and look at some
alternated concept art from Doctor
Strange and the Multiverse of Madness uh
there's one that we talked about right
at the end of 2022 of uh showing an
alternate lineup of the Illuminati it
still had Peggy Carter as Captain
America and looks like we had uh Monica
or Susie Maria Rambo as Captain Marvel
but we had uh either an iron monger or a
Hydra stomper armor in the ball to the
Brave and it sounds like Daniel Craig
was going to be balder the brave based
off what we saw were you guys satisfied
with the Illuminati lineup we got or do
you think they could have done better
yes and I am one of the masses that it
was satisfied because it was the
Fantastic foreign X-Men that is why I
was satisfied that because it's like we
are gonna we're gonna get these twos
soon I know we are but I was very
excited to finally get that nod that
like yes we're gonna get the X-Men and
we're gonna get Fantastic Four don't
worry it's coming so I was content with
it but this would have been sick yeah I
think that signal was like what made the
actual Illuminati that we got like
amazing for me because it's just like
yeah we we have the the Fantastic Four
in mind they were going to play a
crucial part to the MCU story leading up
to Secret Wars so like basically it's
like two words are going to be massive
like we're gonna have mutants we're
gonna have the Fantastic Four and I was
like yeah let's go like like that whole
scene where they mentioned incursions I
was like the the possibilities here are
endless with uh the Fantastic Four in
the secret Wars so yeah I like what we
got more than this personally they come
with so much more extra baggage than
these two and uh and and agreed anyone
can come at me and say Jessica that's
wrong but uh like you even made the
video about like all the instances we've
had the opportunity that Dr Doom is
coming and I think that situation of
like even uh uh Mr Fantastic just like
coming out of that box that belonged to
Doom in the comic books is just enough
to be like oh where is this leading to
it can go anywhere it can go everywhere
so it gives us more baggage to work with
I agree that would have been sick an
iron suit would have been so sick that
that would have been so sick that would
have been great just for the for that
seventh seed of the Illuminati just to
have some big clanking pseudo armor just
to be really loud and and then no one
could hear each other talk because he
keeps shifting in his seat like uh right
please also to watch Wanda tear him
apart would have been very entertaining
he would have been turned into like a
can and then recycled or something or
she would have just like crashed him if
it was Give me Steve in there that would
have been so sad please give me my armor
back the the moment in Infinity War
where Thanos is blasting away Tony's
nanotech armor and we're like oh no no
no it's just flash he's just a weak man
under there what's gonna happen like you
could have had that where one is just
tearing apart the arbor piece by piece
and it takes off his skin piece by piece
and then it's muscle piece by piece and
then his bones one by one bro but like
if they did crush him and like the blood
just started leaking out
Sam Raymond wants that Sam raymie wants
that he was like oh please let me bring
a cheese grater and what about what
happened to uh the hammer Tech guy in
the suit where he just turned around
he's like oh my God and she just keeps
doing it keeps twisting him around and
then just like pulling them apart
[Laughter]
so uh there was some other beautiful
concept art showing the alternate 838
Universe where Wong actually joined
strange and America Chavez that looked
really cool and then some other weird
art of like Professor X looking like the
the X-Men animated series Professor X
and the yellow hovered chair but like in
a real dirty Blade Runner looking uh
Illuminati headquarters
um that's one thing that I wish uh
Multiverse Mattis explored more the
Illuminati headquarters and why it looks
like the British museum like I want to
know who built that was it seemed like
it was the Baxter foundation so is Reed
Richards into it or was that Charles
Xavier saying like I used to come here
as a boy looked at all things that are
British colonizer ancestors took from
the third world to put on display for
Victorian era British people to look at
and we never returned the pieces of the
Parthenon and somehow that's okay like I
I wonder if um if they knew Cersei from
the eternal because like they'll sort of
her Jam being a museum curator and like
you know like that whole Spiel that's
how she knew Dane Whitman so I wonder if
like they teamed up with Dane and Cersei
and like maybe they passed away during
the
um during the Thanos thing but I don't
know have we uh touched on whether or
not the eternals have gone through
different timelines or have they just
stayed in those same timeline the entire
time because there's only one of them
right there's not multiples of the
eternals yeah there are multiples
um like on Earth there's only one batch
on Earth but like
um there are multiples on different
planets yeah there's a whole bunch of
Buzz light years in that world Forge
yeah and uh
I don't remember that concept art
I'll say no I'll say no thank you
um do you guys remember Randy Newman and
then see you oh yeah we're coming to the
MCU okay I'm sorry keep going um so uh I
want to talk about the she Hulk designs
but first I want to thank the sponsors
who helped us make this episode starting
with our friends at nordvpn there are a
ton of options in the MCU when it comes
to telling the stories of some of our
favorite Heroes and Villas but when it
comes to streaming movies and series
online you might feel like there are not
a lot of options one way to get more
content options in your life is to check
out nordvpn with nordvpn you can change
your virtual location with just one
click which makes it easier to find the
streaming platforms at a lower price we
can even access platforms that aren't
even available in the US with just one
click you can choose from over 5400
servers and over 60 countries nordvpn is
there to make sure you never miss out on
your favorite content whether we're at
home or traveling and if you're worried
that nordvpn might cause buffering when
you're watching content fear not nordvpn
provides amazing speed thanks to Nord
links so you can stream securely without
bandwidth throttling nordvpn's benefits
and features go Way Beyond improving
your streaming experience you can also
access games at discounts only available
in other regions and block malware
written websites while you explore or
securely we encourage you to try nordvpn
for yourself so grab your exclusive
nordvpn deal by going to nordvpn.com
Marvel to get a huge discount off your
nordvpn plan plus for additional months
for free it's completely risk-free with
nord's 30-day money-back guarantee
that's
n-o-r-d-vpn.com Marvel for an exclusive
discount plus four months free and
thanks to Helix sleep for sponsoring
this episode let's make 2023 the year of
a good night's sleep here at new
rockstars We Trust Helix to protect our
sleep with the best mattresses in the
world we all have Helix mattresses we
love them Helix sleep has a quiz that
takes just two minutes to complete and
matches your body type and your sleep
preferences to the perfect matches for
you everybody is unique Helix knows that
so they have several different mattress
models to choose from they have soft
medium it firm mattresses mattress is
great for cooling you down if you sleep
hot mattress is great for spinal
alignment to prevent morning aches and
pains and even the Helix plus mattress
for plus size sleepers actually Kelly
and I just rolled out uh since we're you
know now married and uh we are no longer
living in sin but we see we
actually uh he looks got uh we got a
king-sized Helix mattress and so far oh
well the um I won't go into details but
we're getting
just go to healingsleep.com inside
Marvel take their two-minute sleep quiz
and they'll match you to a customized
mattress that will give you the best
sleep of your life they have a 10-year
warranty to get to try it out for 100
nights of a screen Helix is offering up
to 200 off all mattress orders and two
free pillows for our listeners at
helixsleep.com inside Marvel we also
want to thank hover for sponsoring this
episode if you've ever thought about
starting your own business creating a
brand or sharing what you know with the
world the first step is finding a domain
name to get you off the ground hover
makes creating a domain name super
simple you don't even know what you're
doing to get started because hover
provides easy to use tools a
straightforward user experience if you
ever need help their super friendly
support team is there to guide you so
give them a call in a real life person
will assist you hover is a trusted and
popular choice amongst millions of
people launching any kind of brand blog
or business they even provide domain
names that go beyond your standard.com
you can really make your Endeavor stand
out with extensions like dot shop dot
Tech dot art and more they have over 400
domain extensions however's connect
feature makes it so simple to connect
your domain name to lots of website
Builders with just a few clicks if
you're ready to get your ideas online
hover has the domain name to make it
happen head on over to hover.com Marvel
to get 10 off your first purchase that's
h-o-b-e-r.com slash Marvel for 10 off
your first purchase all right let's look
back at the Seahawk concept art I think
remember seeing these after She-Hulk
wrapped we had some alternate designs
for k-e-v-i-n Kevin some uh without the
little ball cap some with the ball cap
just like perched bounced on its head
that's like
we also saw some alternated signs of
Scar that in my opinion look way better
than what we got what are you talking
about
okay look here look here he does the
best he can he is a team he is a child
and when we see him next he might look
like this we don't know how he ages
tired of everybody
yeah I mean
like the concept art is clearly clearly
Superior um this is not a team that is
not I don't care if that thing right
there
he could be a grown man all I need is
and it wasn't there yeah you know if
that hair was on my boy's head it'd be
fine I would be fine with that I get the
I get the I get you guys hating on this
hairline starting back here but
but that that concept art that looks
older than the Hulk that can now Hulk's
got some winner speaks he's got the salt
and pepper coming in now he has to wear
glasses
but I do love that scar that is the scar
I want to see eventually that is the
scarf from the comic books that beats
the crap out of the hole Yeah if you
think about it if scar was on the car
that rhymes
um time works differently there I feel
like time is weird there for some reason
like and I feel like he could be an
adult looking man no potentially I agree
I agree eventually not right now
give us little scarves give us a little
scarf baby Scott but that concept art is
great I love that concept art I want him
to look like that eventually that is
that is the scar I read that beat the
crap out of his dad yeah yes and then
she holds I want to see some green
domestic violence
Mt you know what they do to us when we
say things like that they take us out of
context
I'm just kidding
everyone keep it keep your hands to
yourself it's a brave stance empty
yeah thanks thanks empty No One's Gonna
get mad now that Kevin though is very
fun I love it but I do love what they
ended up with Kevin I like the idea
because it's if this guy is rewriting
all of like television and movies for
Marvel Cinematic Universe for all time
it makes sense that he has the most
rickety form of video like video formats
and I love the idea of him being like
I've been here since it first began
remember the rotoscope remember that
like well the rotoscope is still doing
things but I like the I like what they
ended up with but I do love this little
hat yeah I think in this concept art it
looks a little too like uh not humanoid
but organic right like you can't really
see which of those wires might actually
be a bit fleshy or something like that
it looks too much like a cyborg and I
want Kevin to just be a nice clean
desktop assistant yeah this looks like
one of those robots from The Matrix bro
this looks like it's like a villain yeah
it looks so menacing I'm Kevin with the
I I think it's very funny to put that
hat on him but I love it just as an
afterthought just the tiniest little hat
it's just a hat it's just a hat just a
little hat perched upon his little metal
body all right we gotta move on and talk
about uh the Thor love and thunder
concept art before Russell Crowe was
gonna be Zeus at some point he was gonna
be Satan or a devil or a pistol devil
one of the three look at this sexy beast
my Haitian mother's worst enemy this is
my best enemy this is my best friend
this is the keep your enemies closer
look at him look at his little feet look
at how he's got like a foot just to
munch on he's eating it yeah he's just
you know what it's delicious good
protein I support it what I like about
the idea of this was do you think that
they still hadn't well they had to have
that in mind that he would still be the
leader of the the gods right or not the
leader but like yeah
that version of Thor love and thunder is
way more metal than what we got I think
all we get out of Zeus is the fact that
he's uh he's Hercules dad and it sets up
Hercules other than that imagine like
you know taiku TT want to do a version
of this it's like we'll just let me go
to some dividend City it's actually
Satan it's ready to shoot like that
that's the version of the movie
everywhere didn't they cut out the scene
with Dionysus they did there was a super
Dionysus is drunk he's like hey let's
party yeah so like that feels like it
feels more attached to this guy than it
did our Zeus our Zeus was just about the
the orgy and about his son being
Hercules but this one seems like it
would have been fun to see this as a
leader like that would have been a fun
thing to like introduce it's like hey we
just rotate who's in charge of the Gods
so it's like now it's just the devil's
turn so here's the devil not caring
about everybody but then it would have
also opened so many freaking doors to
like the uh we would have gone
everything crazy everything if we saw
this
we would have been like well this all
has to be here and I think because they
were they're clearly cooking up
something with Mephisto maybe with Sasha
baronco and you know on iron heart and
AG the Covenant of chaos I think that's
why they didn't want any confusion they
wanted yeah 100 agree 100 but I love
what you said was it I think after you
just said like it's his turn cover like
it's an HOA like oh [__] those years as
king of the Gods he's the worst it's
like we've been sort of delaying this
since the beginning of time all right
you can have your turn it's like yeah
speaking of things Mephisto should have
been in one division uh we did see some
concept art a billy and Tommy
disintegrating in Agatha's dungeon that
was from the finale episode billion
times are just kind of like off screen
for a lot of it it's because they had
this subplot where you know uh senior
scratchy was gonna turn into like a
werewolf style demon and chase them
around in a dungeon and this concept art
proves that they they did think about
that you see Ralph over there in the
corner you see Monica Rambo figuring out
what's going on uh do you do you think
we needed Senor scratchy and Billy and
Tommy running away from them in like
this kind of a Goonies scene in the
finale I wanted more senior scratchy and
I think we talked about that during one
division we all wanted more senior
scratchy we thought it was going to be a
bigger part than what he was
uh but I also I I don't think the the
the twins running the kids running would
have wouldn't have really added anything
really yeah because we were too we were
so focused on this and then the other
B-Line storyline was Monica and boner
Ralph boner so it was like
I don't know if it would have added yeah
you go on empty I mean I I think that it
would have added a little bit more to
Billy and Tommy's like presence on the
show because like they have these
superpowers they do super power kids so
like giving them like a sort of like an
antagonist to like either run from or
like fight together would have been
really cool rather than like that very
short moment where uh Hayward shoots
them and then Monica blocks the bullet
they didn't really get a whole lot to do
and like they they obviously fought the
those agents there but like having that
one sequence where it's like all right
this is your sequence you guys like just
go crazy like kids I would have loved to
see that but um I do like one division
as it was so it did flow nicely for me
so I'm not super sad
yeah yeah it just would have been nice
to get some kind of payoff with the
rabbit I think because otherwise right
and I think that could come into play in
in Agatha show oh yes I think she's
gonna bring back Sparky oh that'd be
good and then we're gonna be like does
anyone who give it to White Zombie I'm
sorry that's the one hold up I have with
Agatha Harkness is she killed the dog
and anyone who kills a dog is no hero of
mine hey hey I agree but do you know how
many cats die in shows and movies Alf
eight cats that's right the midnight
mass thing eight cats everyone's eating
cats no man I say this is someone who
loves Kitty cats I love cats um but cats
audiences are just more okay with dying
and I don't think that's a fair standard
you know what Jess you know who doesn't
eat cats Batman so uh
[Laughter]
I was like someone it's gonna be someone
that genuinely doesn't eat it and it's
it's bad bad good job
keep it up you win you win this week
um well we gotta talk about this concept
Earth that just came out from uh in game
although maybe this is out I just didn't
see it well there was going to be a shot
where you start with Spider-Man and
Hulk's Palm Hulk is going to be
launching Spider-Man throwing him and
then we zoom out and Hulk is in giant
man Scott Lang's Palm so it's like a
throw and throw it through a triple
assist this would have been freaking
awesome in the movie amazing absolutely
unreal and it should have been in the
movie like it would have been a really
quick thing but like people would have
gone crazy for it I would have loved it
has uh Ant-Man ever I mean technically
they fought alongside each other but
they didn't really come in contact with
each other because Hulk wasn't in Civil
War right yeah or is that the beginning
of infinity War uh Peter saves Bruce but
Bruce hasn't hulked out but Ant-Man has
Scotland oh yeah he doesn't know Hulk at
all in fact like Bruce is like there's
the name man now yeah
in the Spider-Man so like that would
have been uh even better payoff because
he did mention Ant-Man and Spider-Man so
like him working together with them
would have been like all right this is
what we're doing now sure I mean we did
get a bit of an assist if you look
closely in that end game battle charge
you know I believe Spider-Man's swinging
off of ant-man's hand or something like
that but it's not as cool as this oh
yeah yeah that is cool well he tears him
down in Civil War Spider-Man and uh
Ant-Man he goes for his legs like yeah
he does he trips he mentioned Star Wars
so they go there they come in contact
but it's Bruce doesn't really does it
does it this would have been this would
have been sick all right let's move on
to Loki we saw some concept art we've
talked about this in a ton of videos but
and he remains off as originally there
was going to be an Iron Man helmet on
the Shelf how cool would this happen
about this I I know I brought it up in
like four videos
I haven't seen it yeah yeah so we're
gonna put an Iron Man helmet on he
remains shelf in the Citadel office
to imply that like you know some trophy
taken off the dead Avenger that he
remains held on to was an Iron Man
helmet I really like this detail because
like um in The Avengers uh Cartoon
um Kang is like inspired by Tony Stark
technology
um it inspires a suit and I feel like we
think it could be very much the same
here because considering that we know
the end game Tony Stark is the father of
time travel
um in the MCU as far as you know
obviously uh he remains made it happen
so like I feel like he's just a huge fan
of Tony Stark in general so yeah I feel
like this would have been really cool to
see as a little detail that would have
been so fun and also that if that would
have happened and then we get
quantumania where he's like have I not
killed you yet to Ant-Man and it's like
he's just killing through the Avengers
he's just ripping through y'all
yeah God that would have been so sick it
would be cool if he had like pieces of
everyone's armor it's like yeah like the
WASP swings 100.
Okay and like a real Hellcat
that one you get from Target you know
yeah fake you know this one this is why
they they took it out they were like for
continuity reasons but also like it's
such a hassle probably being like should
we do this there like someone's gonna
figure out that continuity wise this
doesn't make sense right yeah
put in Bucky's arm on there I'm looking
at you James Gunn I'm very upset about
that still
um
and you can say whatever you want on
Twitter you could say it was all that
holiday cheer but it still doesn't make
sense all right the last piece of
concept art we're gonna look at came
from the art of Avengers Infinity War
book and it was some alternate concept
art of Thanos fighting Doctor Strange in
a wizard duel battle we saw a bit of
that in Infinity War but this one would
have had strange hitting thanos's uh
forehead G-spot and he would have taken
him through a crazy trip through the
Multiverse that would have looked insane
including including the trial in front
of the Living Tribunal that declared
Thanos
what do you guys think would this have
made oh that would have been freaky that
would have been sick like whenever we go
to like the higher levels of like Marvel
like Cosmic stuff like I get so excited
like we're seeing eternity in Thor four
I was like this is a big deal guys like
this is like massive so like seeing the
Living Tribunal like judging Thanos like
I would have freaking if that would have
touched my G-spot I would have created
my jeans I like the idea of just like my
favorite things are like one-on-one
fights when it's equal and I mean not
really equal against Thanos but like I
do think this would have been fun to
take him to a different literally like a
wizard duel like off to a different
planet in front of the Living Tribunal I
think that's sick as hell but also it's
like The Avengers movie was clearly it's
a team sport it's a team movie Iron Man
is a lot of the like fixation so I don't
think they would have done that because
it would have been more about doctor
strange but God that would have been
sick as hell yeah you're totally right
and we got a version of this in
Multiverse of Madness you know they did
the whole Multiverse hopping montage and
then we saw strange fighting his
alternate stuff with music notes which
was wild so fun super cool but like just
I mean seeing everything everywhere all
at once Congratulations by the way on
your Oscar nominations these were all so
happy for your movie of all times it
needed more nominations it was so good
give it all the nomination but just the
scenes where Joy is fighting Evelyn in
every hit is knocking them through a
different reality was mwah so much fun I
love her that's perfect this could have
been it okay well all of you watching we
want to know which of these alternate
versions of the movie the concept art
would you prefer to what we got in the
movie we know there's a lot of other
Concepts aren't there out there maybe
we'll do a part two of this episode
sometime in the future but Jessica Mt
thank you so much for joining me this
episode it's been a delight thank you
this has been great you can follow
Jessica at Lulu underscore Clemons you
can follow Mt and ascertainment you can
follow me at EA boss you can follow all
the Deep dive updates that deep dive in
are And subscribe to the Deep dive
Channel Deep dive in our subscribe to
inside Marvel wherever you get your
podcast of course subscribe to new
rockstars a bunch of amazing stuff
that's gonna be coming this year on the
new rockstars Channel we're all so
excited share it with you and we'll see
you next week bye bye everybody
[Music]
foreign